Welcome everybody to another Zoom call where we're going to do our best to answer any of your questions
For those that are new here feel free to chat in any questions that you may
come up with while we're going through these or
forgot to
and
I'll do my best to answer those
Remember also to look at the announcements of the members page and
Don't if there's any new announcements going on
Okay, let's get going with the first question
Why can gluten be an issue for a cancer patient?
So gluten remember gluten is
What is followed in wheat? It's the protein in wheat
rice, spelt, malt, barley
And
Griaedin is actually the protein
And you could have sensitivities to it. So gluten can be inflammatory
So even if you don't have sensitivities, maybe antibodies to gluten or one of its
Part you know particles of gluten which are called peptides of a protein
Even if you don't have antibodies against gluten as an entire molecule or its peptides
It still could be inflammatory
so
It can cause anything that can cause inflammation in your body or
inflammation in your gut can hinder
Your immune system's ability to do other things in this case for a cancer patient to kill cancer cells
So isn't a good idea for cancer patients to go gluten free? Maybe that would be an extension of this
Yeah, that would be a good idea
Is it necessary is gluten ever feeding the cancer?
Typically no gluten is not going to be a feeder of a cancer specific
Glianned as a protein
It's certainly the peptides of glianned are not going to be a fuel source for cancer
But can gluten cause issues with certain cancer patients more than others? Yes
Especially if you have antibodies against glianned or it's peptides you're going to have more inflammation and it's going to cause
more of an issue for a person
So I will not say that
Gluten is always going to cause an issue for a cancer patient and every cancer patient should go off a gluten
You should at least consider, you know, when you're trying to deal with cancer
Sometimes it's easy to ignore other comorbidities that may be even preceded the diagnosis of cancer
AKA would be maybe gut issues and maybe food sensitivity that you never
Really do that you had or did you address prior to your diagnosis of cancer and could have actually been
A piece of the puzzle that broke out your immune system that
Was a piece of the cause of why a person got cancer in the first place. They had other ill health
In this case gut inflammation that um, you know
Helped contribute to a worse diagnosis. So it's never wise to just ignore other health issues just trying to
quote-unquote treat or kill cancer
Um, you have to do a more holistic approach and try to get your whole south more healthy
That's why with all our cancer patients we also address gut health
and um, and that is important because
Your detoxification pathways your gut health here
Your overall whole body health is equally important in order for you to elicit to proper immune response to
kill cancer. So it's all a piece of that. So
Why can gluten be an issue for a cancer patient all those reasons anything that is going to cause inflammation
Is going to decrease your ability to fight an immune elicit immune response to kill cancer
next question
Is it bad to eat butter if I'm supposed to be
Cancer-free. Oh cancer-free. I think the person meant dairy-free
So if you're supposed to be dairy-free
Um, and you are
Can you eat butter?
Um, I get this question a lot. The problem is is that yes butter is dairy
And if if dairy can be driving your cancer then eating butter could be driving your cancer
however the butter of substitutes that are out there are
You know can be worse for you
So I would say that you know if a person was to be dairy-free can they eat a little bit of butter? Yes
I would say you'd better off eating a little bit of butter than eating the butter substitutes
Marjorative things that are out there the
the plant
Oil-based
Butters quote-a-quote that are out there are not good for you
So
You know, there's other substitutes you can have coconut oil you could have
Uh, avocado oil and olive oil, but sometimes you need you're you're putting butter on something is
Is going to be more appropriate than using those other things. So using a little bit of butter
I would say it's fine even if you're supposed to be dairy-free
Remember it's not a it's a diet. It's not a religion. We're not what I mean a cult about your eating here
It's about taking a balanced approach and okay, if dairy is driving my cancer
I'm going to stay 95% dairy-free. It doesn't mean you can't have some dairy
You know the food sensitivity here that if you eat that thing
You're going to cause inflammation. Let's say if you have gluten
You know, your antibodies like the other question we had they have glee added antibodies
And you eat well, I'm just going to I'm pretty much gluten-free
Well, pretty much gluten-free is like being kind of pregnant. You know, you're still going to
cause inflammation every time you eat gluten
You know three times a week and you're and if you have antibodies to
You know, brain cells
Neural antibodies
You're going to cause inflammation of the brain and further destruction so you can't
Just kind of go halfway at a diet like that
But when you're talking about what could be feeding cancer if you've removed most those things that you're
That you're consuming in what could be feeding cancer then you've
You know, having a little bit of it isn't going to cause the cancer to take off and grow
So it's about having that balance
Next question
Is it possible to eat too much salad um
Yeah, so everything is within balance with food here. Well, we discussed um
Can a person eat too much salad though
So remember in your three-ring binder
There's a section that talks about your greens and eating salads can be excellent for you
but
It depends on what you're choosing for your greens
for instance
I really like kale and spinach so if I'm eating my salad with just kale and spinach and I'm making kale and spinach smoothies and such
kale and spinach have the most ability to increase nitric oxide which you necessarily don't want to do
When you have a diagnosis of cancer because excess nitric oxide is going to stimulate
a vascular interthelial
cell growth and could
Increase the growth of a cancer. So you don't want to be doing that
excess salad if you're even eating leafy greens, lettices, arugula
Things like that that aren't necessarily kale
Um, could you eat too much of that? Well, you're are going to have a lot of methyl groups
folate in
foliage
so
Yes, you could
How much is too much? I mean, I don't know. I mean if you're eating you know
Six salads a day on a regular basis. Yeah, then maybe you could can anybody eat too much
I don't know if you could possibly do that
um, I have had patients in the past that came to me as
strict vegans um, so
I don't think that that lifestyle is necessarily healthy for most people for lots of reasons
But one of the reasons is you can get excess folate and
And you're doing so too many methyl groups, which is
contract in
Dictatory for a person with a diagnosis of cancer. So you would have to be careful about that
You can stimulate too much nitric oxide
For a person with cancer. So there everything is within balance
Uh, so I guess yes, you can eat too much salad
Next question
Are people with breast cancer more prone to easy bruising?
Um, no, no people with breast cancer or any cancer, I would say are not more prone to easy bruising
Easy bruising if the person is prone to easy bruising you think of capillary fragility
You think of a person that is on a blood thinner
So if you're on a blood thinner, you can have that you can have
Decrease in platelet formation. So you have decreased platelets
So if you look at a comprehensive metabolic profile, you have a lower platelet
panel um, you
And you're on a blood thinner. You are going to be prone to easy bruising
So the number one positive people with easy bruising is typically an elderly person who's on a blood thinner because of a heart issue that they had
And the doctor never took them off of their blood thinner and told them if they don't go off if they don't stand the blood thinner
They're going to die of a stroke and never tested their
Uh, de-diver they never tested their platelet values
They're never looking at it again many times people got a prescription eight years ago
And the doctor just keeps refilling it never looks at
causative factors again
And and also sometimes what takes place in this they're on a blood thinner
And then they start getting into more natural things and they start taking things like garlic
Which is a natural blood thinner
So they're really getting probably too much thin into the blood
At an increase in bruising where they just didn't even know they bumped themselves and they got bruises all over their arms and their hands
Um, they don't even remember bumping themselves
So it has to do with capillary fragility it has to do with
You know other things that can cause capillary fragility and such
Which could range from a person with lung disease to a person with h pylori to a person with heavy metal toxicity
There's a lot of different causes to capillary fragility
decrease the
Delta
factor of the
Vitamin E you know consumption all sorts of different
causative factors of that but
Have-eat breast cancer or any other cancer is not going to cause any of those so there's other cold morbidities that are going on if that's the case
Next question. I'm having gut aches after eating. Is this a side of food allergies?
Um, it can be
Typically if you have antibodies so you talk about allergies
Um, you're talking about that you have antibodies
IgG and IgA antibodies
To different proteins in food usually
Um, now if you had an IgE antibodies to a food that would be
You like a peanut allergy where you could you know, you need an epipad to deal with this because you could go into
You know
bronchial constriction in this allergic type reaction. We're talking IgG and IgA antibodies to different peptides
and proteins in food
um
If you have food allergies
Will you get an instant ache in your gut after eating
Sometimes quite honestly usually not so usually those reactions take
Hours to even a day
For you to have so it is kind of difficult to identify food allergies simply by your symptoms
Because the gut pain that you might be getting could be what you ate last night
Um, well no, I'm having gut pain right after I eat
Well, there's other reasons why you'd have gut pain right after you eat that is nothing to do with
Having antibodies against that food most common reason for having gut pain after eating is the deficiency in hydrochloric acid
Second most common pay
Reason would go right along with that is that they have uh, insufficiency of digestive enzymes for the pancreas
So that's why I suggest everybody take HCl and digestive enzymes with their meal
Um, because this is a common
Symptom that people get they have they feel bloated after they eat they get gut pain after they eat they feel
Like they're full they have a full tummy and just eat a little bit they get stomach ache after they eat all these different symptoms that go along with
digest with
mal digestion
So again, mal digestion is probably the number one
morbidity in the world that can lead to all sorts of problems
So hypochloridria and decrease
Uh, pancreatic enzyme production
Is the cause of that so supporting that would be the first thing I would think
So if somebody says I really think I should do a food allergy panel and getting gut pain after I eat my first question would be
Are you taking HCl and digestive enzymes?
Well, no, I haven't really taken those well, that's what I would do first before I do a food sensitive
I was all in the submitted questions today. So let's get to your questions
That you sent in on the chat first question
If I follow label directions and take two caps of clear digest before each meal how long does my acid state elevated
If I have a snack should I take one camp?
No, this
Drinking vegetable fruit not smoothie including fiber
Throughout six to seven hours
Today should I take pop a capsule every few hours?
I do have bloating that is bothersome
But it is there I think from the smoothie fiber
Okay, that's a great
leading question to the last question we had or follow up question to the last question
So clear digest is HCl and digestive enzymes and some other things bile and such
So it's there to help you digest your food but what if you're drinking a smoothie all day long
Should you just be popping these throughout the day?
Yes possibly that would be a good thing to do
If it's just you don't want to take HCl on an empty stomach because it'd be sitting in there with no food in your
And it could irritate your stomach
Possibly especially if you've already have damaged stomach wall. That's why if you look at the blog post on
Hypochloridory it does state that if you try a product like clear digest or a product that has HCl in it and it hurts your stomach really bad
That is a red flag that you already have damaged to the lighting of your stomach maybe even a full ulcer
So then you have to back off on that. It's too much and we have to go to
Either you know all the way back to try to heal the light of the stomach with taking
Declasurides licorice and slippery element things like that
Or go back one step and take a little milder acid and ample cider vinegar
However, that's in this question this question is saying
Okay, if I'm eating how long first of all how long is the acid staying elevated in my stomach
After I take clear digest well, it depends on how much food you're putting in there afterward
So if you're taking two near clear digest, let's say and you eat a meal and then
You know half hour later you're gonna drink some of your smoothie
There may not be any left in there at that time because the HCl is being used
It's helping to break down that food that was in there
So therefore it makes sense that if you're gonna eat just a real small meal
You may be only take one if you're gonna eat a bigger meal you take two if you're eating something that you know you already have difficult
Issues with with digestion. Let's say I'm gonna eat a steak that I always know that
If I eat a steak it kind of sits in my gut and while I might take four
You know what I'm gonna eat something that may be more difficult to digest
So you would you would base it based upon what you're eating and how much you're eating
Secondly, I want to address a heated part of this question. You're getting possibly getting
bloated with fiber in your drink
So if I don't know if this is the case because it's not really the full question
But it brought something to mind. Let's say a person is taking a fiber supplement
Let's say they're taking some fiber or some spectrum
And when they do that they feel really bloated after that
Well, that's a sign that you probably should back off on the fiber
If you eat a fiber supplement or a fiber product or you're eating something with a lot of fiber in it and it's causing
You know bad bloated that can be a sign of
Small intestine and bacterial overgrowth. So that's just something to keep in the back of your mind
If you're like well, no, it's not that bad. It helps if I take a digestive enzyme
That's fine, but you may want to back off of the fiber and see if that changes the bloating
Because that's one test that you could kind of self-do for SIBO
Smell the test of bacteria overgrowth is does fiber make you worse
If it does then kind of to re-adoculate your small intestine
Before you add fiber back something to keep in mind
But the real question is should you take clear digest with smaller meals should you take clear digest with
Uh, some smoothie that's your tricky throughout the day. Yes
Can you maybe an extension of this question? Could you take too much of it?
Yes, but you would get a you if you took too much
HCl you'd get a stomach ache right at the bottom of your ribs right at the bottom of your sci-foid process
so
That would be the only thing and if you took
If you took even one or two and you got that stomach ache
That would tell us that you might have something else, you know, other damage to your stomach lining
That would be for people who are just starting to take a HCl product. There's a lot of people that are
have got issues
We recommend clear digest or an HCl product. They start taking it and it hurts way worse
That's a sign that they quite possibly have it also
We have to back off on that and follow the protocol that I listed that blog post on hypochloridria
um to heal the stomach first
Next question from the chat for a butter substitute
I used a teva organic butter flavored coconut milk
Any problems with that
Um, I have not seen that product. I don't know what they flavor the coconut oil with
So organic butter flavored coconut oil
Um, I don't know I would be I'm just I'd be in the pessimist here
I'd be lary of what they're actually using as a flavor read
And remember if it says natural flavor read
It can still be NSG. So be careful of that
So you'll never see
Montessortium glutamate the label anymore. They could use natural and or artificial flavor read
as the code word for
Montessortium or other glutamates
Which are flavor enhancers. So I would just be careful of that
Next question from the chat what foods etc should one avoid if you are prone to kidney stones
So if you're prone to kidney stones you could have a problem with oxalates most kidney stones are oxalate based
Uh, so stay away from foods that are have high oxalates with so you could google
Foods with high oxalates you're going to see rhubarb you're going to see um
Spinage your I don't know everything else, but it would be high oxalate foods
Um, that would be really the thing to stay away from we have a product from professional health products
That's called oxalate scavenger
Um, that might be something to think about adding as well
That can grab on to oxalates in your gut to help you ex
Excreate them people that are prone to kidney stones
Back in the day we used to call people quote unquote stoned formers
People that are stoned formers are tend to absorb a lot of oxalates
Whereas most people will excrete oxalates in their gut
But if you absorb a lot of oxalates
You could be prone to kidney stones
Gaul stones
bladder stones you could be prone to um
Tendonitis with laid out of calcium so calcific tendonitis
calcific spur formation
Uh, we'd see that a lot when you take an x-ray of somebody's ankle or foot and have these spurs on their tendons
Uh, those are people that would be considered used to be the old term was called bone formers or stoned formers and
Those are people that absorb a lot of oxalates now there can be
Reasons why a person absorbs a lot of oxalates genetically they're the oxalate genes
And there can be just got issues why somebody absorbs a lot of oxalates, but there's a product from php
Called oxalates scavenger
And that could help grab on to oxalates and get rid of them when you're got
Next question from
Extension the last question is a bloated is not bothersome
Okay, so it may not have anything to do with the fiber, but I'm just saying if someone has really bad bloated after they eat a fiber
Some of them and usually we know that by if I
If I prescribed a sunscreen or a sun
Um, fiber as a product and they said oh my gosh, I can't take that because I dispel completely bloated afterwards
That's a dig dig dig dig dig dig dig
That person's got seabull so we have to back off put them on a
Buturate product and some gut healing products before they're able to to go back on any type of fiber
Um, but it would be a very noticeable and bothersome bloating
next question
I am concerned
Should I be concerned if my cancer antigen
CA 27 29 blood test result is 22.4
Rage is 0 to 38.6 and 22.4 on
50 on the CA 153 range 0 to 25 they both seem to be climbing a little each time tested
So with any blood test you're looking at trends
Um, should that cause concern if I'm trending up on two of my two rebarkers
So one of the two rebarkers that is fairly specific to breast cancer CA 27 29 and the other one fairly specific to breast cancer CA 15 3
Are trending up but are still within normal range of this person should they be concerned
Well, I would say it depends it depends are you you compare that with other objective findings
What is the rest of my blood work look like if I get a more endemic on a
On a CBC with differential
No, that stayed steady. I'm good with that and I have a more
um, you know any changes in my
Comprehensive metabolic profile
You know is my
Good phosphatase up is my are my other liver markers up. It's my calcium levels up. No, those are all fine
Then subjective data have by feeling worse
No, I'm feeling great. I'm feeling I'm just as much energy as before
With the breast tumor and can I palpate it any more than before? No, it doesn't feel any bigger or anything
Then I would say no, you don't need to worry about it all. Well, first of all, I'd say you don't need to worry at all anyhow because
That will do us no good, but should I be concerned to look a little deeper
Maybe I would look at those things if if uh
normal uh
If if my two rebarkers were within normal limits
But we're trending slightly upwards and you know also accompanied me feeling worse
Uh, you know, I'm feeling like the
Dodgel is getting larger the two were getting bigger by breast and there was other
Changes in other blood work. Yeah, then we should look at that as
Uh, we need to dig a little deeper. So you compare that with other things. These are still within normal limits
Um, so it's not something to be alarmed at anyhow
But you want you want to be wise. So I would compare that with
other objective and subjective data
Before I'd come to that conclusion
next question
does too much smoothie mix stuff
decrease the effects of bedbenzo
so
That's too if you're putting a bunch of different things in your smoothie with bedbenzo
I think that's the question. Does it decrease the effects of bedbenzo?
Um, no, I mean, no
Um, you should still be able to absorb bedbenzo and it's going to be it's completely different than the other stuff
So no, no, it shouldn't
Decrease the effects of bedbenzo
No
um
Does I could be eight if took bedbenzo with your meal you got a whole bunch of food in your god
Is that going to decrease the effects? You don't need to take bedbenzo in an empty stomach
Matter of fact, it's been shown that that bedbenzo is more
Better absorbed if you take it with fat
So if you take it with a meal you got some fat in that meal
It's going to be better absorbed so no, I wouldn't I wouldn't say that's decreasing the effects at all no
Next question
Dr. Cutters on my call today. I checked my last Syrex and I saw cashews
Vasylid are these the same as raw organic have Vasylid
These were not listed out of range, but are listed under the equivocal
What does that mean not a good idea to eat it was one in 1.69
Okay, if I read bedbure correctly that
Syrex array 10 so a Syrex array 10 is testing
100 or so foods
Some cooked some raw because cooking some foods changes the protein in the food
So you could actually have antibodies to cooked something and not to raw something
um
But with the nuts
the question is um
Is do
uh
cashews
Vasylid have to raw organic have Vasylid I'd say yes
They do
But
The test that you did it is now August the test that you did I think was in January
You could basically throw this out because if you've been away from cashews for you know several months
It's a very good chance that you don't have those antibodies anymore
So if you have self antibodies let's say you have antibodies to your thyroid gland
So we did a test on you a complete thyroid profile. Let's say you have thyroid globular antibodies, okay
Common antibody to have
Therefore you have an autoimmune disorder that's attacking your thyroid
And you have to be careful of certain things and not eat bloated and all this stuff and I have all this information about
autoimmune thyroid
Called Hashimoto's on an autoimmune course, but the news is this is an example
You can have those antibodies your whole life no matter how well you eat no matter how
Well you support your thyroid those antibodies may never go away
Um, but with foods um if you stay away from a food for a period of time
The majority of foods those antibodies will dissipate. They're not gonna stay around you don't
You know you always will have a thyroid, okay, so you could always have antibodies against it if you
You developed an autoimmune disease against your thyroid. You don't always have cashews in your body
So if you stay away from cashews
Your your B cells are gonna be continuing to make antibodies against them. That's a whole idea of eliminating those from your diet
And those can dissipate almost always dissipate
The only ones that tend not to dissipate is gluten because there's so much hidden gluten that stuff
so um
You know, many times people with a gluten sensitivity have to stay off gluten from their life
If you have we do a Cyrex 10 and you have other foods that show up in the yellow or in the red
That's the equivocal or in the out of range red
Um, and you stay away from those for even three months and you did the test again those could be gone
So looking back at a test that you did six plus months ago
It's kind of a mute point
um, if I had antibodies in the equivocal range to any food six months ago
Um, I would indeed hesitate eating it now
If I had stayed away if I've never stayed away from them once and I was eating it every day
Even after getting that test done then you probably still have antibodies that it might even be in the out of range
Red zone, but if you stayed away from those for the most part
They may be all gone. So it's kind of a what you look at a
At a test. It's like looking at a blood test that you did eight months ago and making clinical decisions off that you
Your body's changed
Um, it's not worth looking at the test except to know trends
Um, um, um, your body's changed
So I would not make any clinical decisions based upon a food sensitivity test done
More than you know a month or so ago because your body changes
Okay
Next question you gave me the ingredients of the betyba
Ingredients organic refined, expelled, or pressed coconut oil
Organic natural flavors organic anato extract for color
Yeah, I mean we just don't know what's in the organic natural flavors
Um, could be organic minus only glutamate, but
That's the sad thing about life. What are you gonna do? So you have to pick your mammals
So um, yeah, if you like that I would eat it all up to look that up and see what if that looks good
Um, yeah, I don't think that's an issue. It doesn't have any
Now GMO fermented plants no sunflower
Uh, so yeah, I would I would if you like that that's fine
And follow up in the previous question you many need cashews often
If you've any cashews often and it wasn't the equivocal range probably just lay off of or while you don't want to go to the expensive
Of doing another syrax 10 then just stop eating and they were you
You missed that one or something or you were only staying off the red ones
Uh, in the all of range things that's fine
I would just if they were in the equivocal in the past and you don't want to do it other syrax 10 that
Makes sense to just well. I'm just not gonna eat them
Now, maybe I should just see off and switch to something else
It's always good, you know, we tend to as humans
get into
I'm right with our diets that we eat the same thing all the time
And I just don't think I'd preach this over and over again. I just don't think
That we were created to eat
To be able to eat apples year-round
Um, amusement apples as an example. We were supposed to eat things in season. We're supposed to have a seasonal diet
We're supposed to have a rotational diet
Um, you know, I think there's benefit to that and most people that listen to me right now could it could remember the day
When you went to the grocery store and it was one fourth one
10th the size of the grocery store is today
And you know in
In January, there were there were no strawberries for sale
No, there were any blueberries, you know for sale that you couldn't get a watermelon
Um, these days they're shipping from all over or they're grown in greenhouses there
You know, we get in from Peru and you know, we have things completely out of season to us
Um, and even not so, okay, well that's store
Well, again, you didn't necessarily have the ability to eat cashews on a you know daily basis all your own
Um, we just didn't have the ability to have so much food in front of us all the time
So I think there's a huge benefit
For our gut in our microbiome
I have to have a very rotational diet. There's many studies out there now
That the greater diversity of food that we consume it changes our microbiome when our microbiome
Of the flora that's in our gut can change
Very quickly with food diversity if we just changed our diet where we're eating a lot of different foods
And a lot of rotational foods that are weak in a in one week our microbiome could be completely
changed
And that could bring a lot of health and and decrease a lot of co-orbidity
So think about that as well
Okay, with that, I think I'll say goodbye. Thank you for being on
Tonight and dub
continue to be prayed for
Everybody and us as we pray for you have a blessed week
Bye-bye